you had told your parents that you
wanted to be an actor and you had said
that they were hard-working people and
they work sometimes three jobs and they
didn't want that for you because they
wanted you to go to it was it med school
they had a they had a second and third
grade education Xand life was rough for
them they met my they were never on
welfare never public assistance they
thought that that was shameful for them
my mother worked to judge my father
worked two and three jobs and because
they knew of what not having education
that they insisted at my sister I go to
school and those days they told you what
you're gonna do you're gonna be a doctor
because doctors make money so you're
gonna take some pre-med courses so I was
at those Community College and taking an
oddity in physiology and cutting up
squamous a camp T it Cathy us and cats
and my bedroom spell oh I smelled like
formaldehyde and you know cutting veins
and arteries and seeing the intestines
and it was fascinating from an artistic
point of view but gory as hell
I mean God bless doctors man I mean
really for real it they do it every day
but it wasn't for me they said okay you
failed those courses okay you're not
gonna do that while you're writing all
the time you're not very outgoing you're
writing your journal gonna be an English
teacher okay
that's why I got a scholarship to Boston
University not Luther King scholarship
in English and I was there for the
second year I think it was and I'd
fallen asleep for the third time in my
Chaucer class Old English and Middle
English and Chaucer
god I mean I'm the same not blasting
Chaucer II but Chaucer is rough I
couldn't take it I fall asleep kicked
out of class I was gonna just go back to
the Kip see and just try to get a job at
IBM my roommate if your hick says you
always been you know you were in that
play at Dutchess Community College you
say you liked acting the Emperor Jones
you always want to do something like
that you told your parents and they just
shut you down
look you're gonna go back to Kipp see
how much get one more show just go up to
the School of the Arts and talk to the
guy Lloyd Richards and see if we'd let
you in let me just were the first black
director on Broadway did Raisin in the
Sun a serious play and so I went up it's
a guy I got in and lo Richard became my
mentor after I followed him to NYU
School the arts gave my first job at the
Negro Sowell company and I'm here today
because of Lloyd Richards became his
assistance on the film heated here so
because of him and I play omage to him
all the time he wouldn't allow me to
give up and don't matter how hard it was
he said you're not he says you're
shaming me
you